hey et Canada it's Sean hook and welcome
to the set of my new music video for
never let me let you go the concept of
the video it's really cool it's a bunch
of vignettes and it's basically a mix of
performance and then kind of the
narrative between the relationship
between the the love interest and myself
the song itself is about that awkward
stage and after a breakup you're trying
to get over that person and trying to
distance yourself and they just keep
sending you texts a little sympathy here
and there and it's kind of confusing not
confusing the chemistry between Sean and
his real-life girlfriend of over four
years Kendall who also stars with him in
the video when we were casting the
leaveners for the video I didn't even
have her in mind I'm not the artist like
I got to use my girlfriend like I'll use
my girlfriend but the producer was like
you know I think given the content of
this video you guys obviously have a
comfort in front of each other
she'd be perfect for it and so she yeah
she's she's on board first comes love
then comes making out on camera so
logically that means the wedding's next
right when the timings right it'll
happen everyone has their journey so for
me you know and Kendall it'll happen
when it happens and I feel like it's
going to a really positive place
you